[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ
welt heute gibt cupcakes und zwar habe
ich mir gedacht läuten wir doch so ein
bisschen den frühjahr und sommer ein und
machen schöne sommer cupcakes und zwar
eignen sich aber auch ganz gut muss ich
sagen zu ostern aber auch jetzt einfach
so schön und warm und jahreszeit wenn es
eben mal wieder etwas wuchtiger sein
darf und zwar habe ich hier ist es ja
auch schon die sehen richtig richtig
hübsch aus ich habe einen vanille
zitronen muffin in der mitte habe ich
eine richtig tolle frucht einlage aus
kirschen und himbeeren und obendrauf
eine zweierlei creme nämlich multi
vitamin und kirsche und das ganze sieht
echt hübsch aus und ist auch ganz
einfach herzustellen also mit ein paar
tipps und tricks schafft auch er dass
die creme so auf zu spritzen und zwar
habe ich in diesem rezept oder werde ich
in diesem rezept die neue gruppe von
capri sun benutzen brisant ist ein
unternehmen was bei uns aus der region
kommt muss ich sagen aus eppelheim also
tatsächlich fahren wir da auch sehr oft
vorbei wenn wir auf der autobahn sind
und murat hat schon gesagt apple haben
soll nach capri sun richten muss ich der
sache mal nachgehen dort war ich nämlich
noch nicht aber wie gesagt möchte ich in
diesem video einfach diesen sirup
verwenden den sirup gibt es einfach in
vier geschmacksrichtungen die stelle ich
euch gleich vor wir haben übrigens auch
immer bei uns in mannheim im laden im
museumsshop immer capri-sonne für unsere
gäste und besucher und die bekommt dann
jeder immer kostenlos mit das finde ich
immer ganz schön wenn man bei uns rein
kommt weil man dann einfach schon mal
was zu trinken hat und dann bekommt man
da auch noch snacks und kaffee und tee
und ja deswegen heute gibt es wie gesagt
diese cupcakes und ich werde es zuerst
noch mal anfangen und den muffins teig
zubereiten für den teig nämlich 21 250
gramm sahne 50 gramm mineralwasser mit
kohlensäure etwas vanille extrakt saft
und abrieb einer zitrone 200 gramm mehl
backpulver und natron oder ihr verwendet
einfach das bak mehr da ist backpulver
schon mit dabei 150 gramm zucker etwas
salz und wenn ihr möchtet gerne noch 50
gramm ja und jetzt verrät ihr erstmal
die flüssigen zutaten das heißt sahne
mineralwasser und vanille extrakte in
einer schüssel
[Musik]
geht ganz fix brauchen auch gefahr gerät
dann nehmen wir euch die zitrone und
gibt ein bisschen abrieb dazu wenn er es
gerne zitronig hat dann gibt gerne den
ganzen abrieb dazu ansonsten mache ich
es immer ganz gerne so dass ich
den zitronen ablief einfach aufbewahren
wenn ich einmal nicht alles brauche und
da kann ich das schön einfrieren und
dann eben bei bedarf einfach verwenden
muss ein tiefkühlfach und dann muss ich
die zitrone nicht verschwinden dann
nehme ich lieber den ganzen april von
der bill stone
bis dahin muss nämlich noch dann den
zitronensaft dazugeben
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier noch die
trockenen zutaten nämlich back mehl
zucker und salz die gebe ich auch gleich
mit rein und falls ihres backen
verwendet dann wirklich kein backpulver
kein mehl dazugeben denn da ist einfach
schon genügend back drittmittel drin
ansonsten würde dieses überdosieren als
ich hab schon aus der community kursen
bisschen raus gehört dass sie meine
standard rezept oder meine basis rezept
für muffins gemacht haben und dann weil
eben natron dabei steht einfach noch mal
drunter zu beginnen aber das braucht ihr
nicht beim bak melder müsst ihr einfach
nur das bak mehr leben und fertig
einfach nichts mehr dazu geben und die
trockenen zutaten jetzt nur kurz
einrühren ihr wisst sobald mehr dabei
ist darf nicht lange gerührt werden
ansonsten werden die cupcakes oder
machen uns oder gebäck nicht schön
fluffig und luftig sondern einfach
menschlich um fest
[Musik]
es gebe ich hier noch die mandeln in die
förmchen unten rein und dann fühle ich
darin teig drauf
und zum einfüllen nehmen die am besten
einen großputz in ihrer
[Musik]
und dann können die muffins gebacken
werden
[Musik]
meine cupcakes sind jetzt gefragt und
ausgekühlt ich nehme die immer nach dem
backen direkt raus auf und absolvierte
dann geht es auch sehr schnell jetzt
kommt der fruchtige part nämlich die
frucht einlage und dafür nehme ich zu
meinem himbeeren aus dem tiefkühlfach
ihr könnt aber auch frische gerne nehmen
ich nehme nur gerne immer welche aus dem
tiefkühlfach wir nehmen gerade keine
kinder saison ist deswegen habe ich doch
immer auf vorrat und dann werde ich
jetzt hier däne capri sonnen sirup dazu
verwenden und zwar gibt mir jetzt ganz
neu in vier geschmacksrichtungen nämlich
kirche multi orange und waldfrucht also
bei remix und das ganze ist praktischen
konzentrierter sirup der dann zum
beispiel als getränk zubereitet werden
kann also im verhältnis 1 zu 9 das heißt
ihr nehmt ein teil vom sirup und neun
teile wasser das bedeutet dass er aus
dieser einen flasche da sind 600
milliliter drin 6 liter getränk bekommt
und das ist echt cool und ich habe mir
jetzt gedacht ich nehme den jetzt zum
backen dieser cupcakes und eben für die
frucht füllung und später aber auch für
die creme da bekomme ich nämlich einen
schönen geschmack rein wie gesagt habe
ich jetzt hier meine himbeeren hier
nehme ich jetzt einfach den kirsch sirup
und gebt den hiermit dazu einfach so
etwa 50 gramm und dann kann ich soeben
die himbeeren mit kirsche aromatisieren
und kann das schon einkochen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt schön einkochen lassen bis es so
ein bisschen dickflüssig ist
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr das jetzt
so lassen also sieht auch ganz schön an
der konsistenz wie toll das glänzt und
schein dickflüssig ist und wenn ihr
möchtet last er ist so aber bei mir im
team mögen es die meisten ganz gerne
ohne himberg gerne deswegen passt sehe
ich sitz hier noch durch ein sieb
[Musik]
so sieht die frucht klasse jetzt aus
richtig schön elastisch abkühlen und ihr
könnt da im prinzip eben auch einen
cocktail eurer wahl zu bereiten ich habe
zierkirsche wäre aber ihr könnt
natürlich auch andere früchte mit den
verschiedenen sirup varianten
kombinieren und euren eigenen geschmack
zaubern wie gesagt dass ständig kurz zur
seite und werde jetzt schon mal die
zutaten richten für das topping für die
creme und da mache ich jetzt zweierlei
krems nämlich eine käsecreme und eine
rote creme ich schau jetzt mal ich
glaube aber ich nehme multivitamin und
kirsche dann kommen wir nicht die zwei
geschmacksrichtungen
für die multi frucht creme verwende ich
250 gramm frischkäse im doppel ram stufe
100 gramm des capri sun sirups in multi
frucht 200 gramm sahne und seiner fahrt
zum steif schlagen
okay ich hab jetzt also diese vier
zutaten finde ich ganz schön denn ich
kann praktisch den zucker einfach
weglassen den puderzucker nehmen
stattdessen den sirup und der hat ja
schon diesen multi fruchtgeschmack das
heißt da spare ich mir einfach jetzt
früchte einzukochen oder was anderes
dazu zu geben und habe so einfach einen
schönen geschmack und vor allem ganz
wenige zutaten
es gebe ich den frischkäse hier rein
darauf achten doppel raum stufen damit
auch die creme später schön hält und
dann jetzt den sirup einleben und kurz
berühren
[Musik]
dann gebt ihr hier langsam die sahne
dazu
und spürt die creme mit seiner platte
[Musik]
für die creme verwende ich die gleichen
zutaten bis auf den carlson sirup dann
nehme ich natürlich dann kirsche
[Musik]
ich habe hier mein fruchtpüree das fühle
ich jetzt kurz hier in diese dosen
flaschen
da kann ich es besser einfüllen aber ihr
könnt auch einfach einen spritzbeutel
oder gefrierbeutel nehmen wenn ihr
möchtet
das klappt auch hervorragend und erkennt
ihr jetzt hier die capex vorbereiten und
zwar die sind jetzt heute ein bisschen
anders aufgegangen und so und ich glaube
es lag nicht an der sonne aber das macht
gar nichts denn das mit oben sowieso weg
geschnitten und dann kommt da eine
kleine öffnung rhein am besten mit einem
apfel entkernt zum beispiel und dann
habt ihr hier so ein kleines fach
erfüllt das fruchtbare
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier meine beiden krems
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr sie auch
gerne optisch noch ein bisschen
voneinander trennen indem ihr sie
einfärbt das habe ich freund hat sich
einfach kurz vergessen ich mache jetzt
hier einen teil und da einen teil und
dann fertig sie rein und hab dann auch
einen schönen optischen effekt ich nehme
jetzt hier einfach lebensmittel
verpassten in gelb rot und rosa und
mache die multi creme so ein bisschen
gelblich und die anderen bisher rosa
[Musik]
wenn ihr die kleine portion creme
eingefärbt habt dann gibt es sie zur
großen portion und können sie dann
vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
nämlich jetzt einen großen spritzbeutel
und hier dieser stelle das ist eine
schöne große ställe mit 14 mm
durchmesser damit muss ich sagen
spritzig die cupcakes immer am liebsten
weil sie dann einfach eine schöne schöne
optik bekommen und jetzt
muss ich schaffen es hinzukriegen denn
normalerweise macht man das mit
zweifarbigen krems so dass man auch drei
spritzbeutel benutzt das heißt ein
spritzbeutel wird gefüllt mit der gelben
creme einer wird gefüllt mit rosa beide
werden aufgeschnitten und in einen
master spritzbeutel reingesteckt ich
find tatsächlich was funktioniert ganz
gut aber man kann es auch ohne drei
spritzbeutel machen weil ich finde dass
ich schon bisschen 4 dh ich fühle jetzt
die eine hälfte mit gelb und versucht da
auch relativ am rand zu bleiben und
deswegen ist hier einen spritzbeutel
ständer echt ganz ratsam
am besten parallel rosa auf die andere
seite und
dann habe ich zwei krings
so seht ihr sitzt von außen
aussagen des perfekt gefüllt
jetzt hier oben verschieben
er ist echt gut gemacht habe dann ist es
wirklich halb halb und jetzt haltet ihr
den strip viertel immer schön senkrecht
und dann spritzt ihr einfach so einen
schönen turm auf ich starte immer in der
mitte und dem spritzbeutel am besten so
ansetzen dass er nicht so tief ist also
die spitze soll halt nicht eintauchen
sonst jetzt nicht schön das heißt immer
schön von oben
schöner sommer früher kaputt
[Musik]
stelle kurz den kühlschrank damit sie
schön kühlen kann und dann werden sie
nun feststeht
da sind sie die schönen cupcakes und ich
finde sie jetzt schon echt richtig schön
und ihr könnt sie auch gerne so lassen
aber so ein bisschen deko möchte ich
schon noch drauf machen und zwar habe
ich hier zum einen kleine opladen blüten
die sind echt schön die schmetterlinge
sind auch schon auch die kleinen
bienchen und zum streuen nämlich so ein
bisschen am rand des bereits geprüft und
dann setze ich hier einfach so eine
minimalistische de groot oft
ich finde mal so ein bisschen kindlich
machen möchte nimmt man noch
schmetterlinge und größere blümchen dazu
möchten so schon echt schön
und die blümchen und schmetterlingen
aber am besten vor dem verzehr aufsetzen
das ist nämlich erst papier der vorteil
ist das ist nicht so hart wie normaler
zucker strecke und das ist einfach schön
der kleine nachteil ist natürlich
esspapier nimmt natürlich feuchtigkeit
auf deswegen kurz vor dem verzehr
einfach draufsetzen
[Musik]
bei bedarf im morast cupcakes probieren
gab
frisch außen gab endlich mal wieder und
zwar habe ich hier cupcakes gemacht wann
die letzte drohne eine frucht einlage
mit kienberg und mit zweierlei creme und
zwar multi frucht und kirsche und jenes
nicht kirsche des bmx kirche und was ich
noch dazu sagen möchte das hier in der
capri sun keine künstlichen aromen drin
sind keine farbstoffe und auch keine
zusätze also das für mich echt schön und
dass man hat auch aus einer flasche echt
6-liter
gefängnis ist getränkt bewahrt also auch
schon gesagt das machen wir schon seit
zwei jahren hat schon seit der eröffnung
im shop ist wirklich so dass wir den
leuten wenn sie bei uns im shop reingeht
einfach einen in die hand drücken klar
weil die leute ist einfach freuen und
sagen herr kuhlmann kommt was kostenlos
von jetzt nicht übertreiben brauchen
jeden tag kommt aber es ist einfach
schön so jetzt brauche ich mal und ich
weiß der branche normalerweise immer
rein aber darf ich dir denn cupcake weil
der hat so eine schöne frucht führung
darf ich dir denn mit dem löffel warte
mal kurz das auflösen könnte das ab
schon etwas gelöffelt
versorgt
guckt euch das mal an bitte das läuft
raus damit
also wenn ich sage nochmal so schmid
kleckern
ich bin den geschmack kommen woher ich
weiß aber ich vorher vielleicht bei der
capri sonne jetzt kommt es die harpstedt
sowie mehr kaffee sollen das heißt capri
sun genau jetzt international sich ja
mal und schon auch die frage wenn es
wirklich lachen zu mir kommen manchmal
leute in den laden und sagen wenn sie
diesen trend haben und wieso heißt es
sind wir kamen es ist wirklich so hält
globaler globaler geworden ist ich
glaube das hat 50 jahre leicht mittels
falsches sagen hieß es glaubt capri
sonne und dann machst dann plötzlich
glauben soll so ist es halt
international und die belieferten nicht
nur deutschland sondern eben auch andere
länder von daher finde ich das ganz
praktisch weil es dann eben nur noch ein
name ist 115 minuten poliert bord der
iss richtig lecker und fruchtig und ich
habe ganz vergessen ich hatte ja dann
noch so ein quatsch mit dabei im boden
da ist richtig gut also probiert das
rezept gerne aus ihr findet sie wie
immer in meiner app und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken probiert
unbedingt diese zweierlei creme aus sehr
lecker ich finde es schmeckt wie so ein
leichtes ice
warten auf die anderen probleme geht es
nun gleich schmecken auch so neben den
geschmacksrichtungen ja nicht die creme
waren zwei geschmacksrichtungen
das ist multi frucht und der recherche
bis gar nicht mehr befreien gestoppt da
muss halt noch einmal sehen also viel
spaß nur nach backen bis zur nächsten
liebe grüße nach
so
[Musik]